[Music]
marshall is in boise idaho marshall
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call how are you
i'm doing wonderful how can i help today
good i'm not quite as young as your last
caller i'm 44. okay hey that's still
young man give yourself some credit well
okay thanks
i'll try to remember that uh just moved
here from virginia and i kept my house
in virginia that i'm renting out and
then i'm renting an apartment
in boise in the boise area and i'm
trying to decide whether it's smart to
hold on to my house in virginia or not
i'm single uh one small dog you got a
single you're single and a dog and
you're renting right now are you wanting
to own a home in the boise area are you
there long term
don't know yet
but you're working in boise currently
i am and it's not
you're going you're going into the
office and all that you've got some
roots there
i i'm going in to teach children math
and uh i don't know how long i'll be
here but at least for the next year
okay
well you know i don't i don't love the
idea of being a long-distance landlord
i'm sure you have you've got to have
something set up to where you know if
the hvac goes out you've got someone to
call right
yes i have a company who takes about 80
bucks a month to kind of manage things
okay
yeah long term i want to see you with
your with a primary residence paid off
and then getting into real estate
investing so if i'm in your shoes
personally what i would do is sell that
house take that money and if you think
you're gonna plant roots in boise at
least for a few years you can go ahead
and find something in the boise area and
work aggressively to pay that off do you
have any other do you have any debt
currently
i've got about eight grand in student
loan debt and i've got about 25 in the
bank
for my emergency fund oh okay you have
25 in cash in the bank i thought you
meant you had debt i was like you have
debt in the bank how does that work okay
so we've got eight grand of student
loans and then do you owe anything on
that property
i owe 110
and i could sell it tomorrow for
probably 220. oh
well that's a nice chunk of chain so
you'll you'll have about a hundred grand
if you sell it in cash
yep well i want to see these still
student loans paid off i mean it's not a
ton here you could get rid of it without
having to sell the home so it's not a
there's no urgency there but if i'm you
i'm selling that house uh taking a
portion of that money getting rid of
these student loans you've already got
that emergency fund i would even take
down that emergency fund and get rid of
these student loans today regardless of
the home sale
okay what's making you happy is you're
nervous but what's what makes you
nervous about this
i just like having that that money in
the bank in case of an emergency
do you do you like paying your student
loan payment
uh i do not
well i guess you got to decide
well i haven't had to pay it in a while
but yeah i mean it's the next thing to
go i just wanted to maybe get up to
maybe around 30 grand in the bank before
i
paid that off well you'll still be in a
great financial spot even paying off
this loan you'll still have what 17
uh grand or so
16 grand so you're still going to be in
a great spot uh for an emergency fund's
sake i'm sure that's still at least a
few months worth of expenses but without
that payment you're going to have a
little bit of income back in your life
to put towards your next goal which i
assume would be are you investing
currently
um i
contribute to a 401k at work and and
have been contributing to a 403b at my
last job for about 18 years
okay nice so i mean you're doing you're
doing some good things there's a slight
it's slightly out of order from what we
teach uh where i want you to pay off
that debt first you have the cash on
hand you can do that today and then you
can continue investing uh once you build
that emergency fund back up to where you
want it three to six month range i
assume since you're
you're single you want it closer to six
months
yes okay yep
what were you saying so you think you
think get rid of that that house
i would personally because you don't
have a primary residence that's paid off
if you had a primary residence that's
paid off and this thing was still
lingering uh and it didn't bother you
that much but it's still a long distance
situation and you don't have a house
that you're living in and so i want to
see you debt free completely house and
everything before you get into uh real
estate investing so there's no there's
nothing on fire here but if i'm in your
shoes you're going to put yourself in a
really sweet financial position when you
have six figures in cash and now you
have some options when you want to you
know go go put 20 down on a place in
boise or wherever you end up planting
your roots
okay
well that helps and i appreciate your
time absolutely marshall thanks so much
for the call